okay so um unfortunately marilina
vasinal can't uh couldn't couldn't be
here but um
she will be at the round
table um
so you can keep your questions to direct
directly to her then i guess um and uh
she um so she did her her phd and um at
princeton she has a sort of a psychology
and economics background and uh is
currently starting at uh at nyu
um
so uh
yeah i guess let's just uh let's watch
the video and you can keep your
questions and hopefully we can we can
bring them into the panel discussion
hi thank you for coming to my talk i am
adelina vlastiano i'm an nyu
postdoctoral fellow and incoming
assistant professor of psychology
and before nyu i obtained my phd in
psychology and neuroscience from
princeton university
where i studied collective phenomena
emerging from sociocognitive processes
and this work was mostly motivated
by events happening in 2016
when large-scale targeted misinformation
campaigns started taking over the world
with critical consequences
over in the uk citizens were led to
believe that the british economy would
benefit from leaving the european union
and in accordance with this belief they
voted in the 2016 brexit referendum
a decision that a majority of voters
then regret it when faced with the
actual consequences of brexit
in that same year in the united states
another such misinformation campaign led
people to believe a vast amount of false
information which was a critical
component in the 2016 presidential
election
and these examples are not isolated
incidents
people's susceptibility to holding false
beliefs spends topics and is consistent
over time
for example
a third of americans believe global
warming is a conspiracy
and a third of american parents believe
vaccines cause autism and holding false
beliefs can have dire consequences
as false beliefs have been associated
with increased climate change denial
decreased vaccination rates
and increased intergroup prejudice
therefore in my work i'm interested in
understanding how we can change false
beliefs in vulnerable communities
but first what are beliefs and how do
beliefs change
in my work i operationalize beliefs as
the mental acceptance
of the truth of a statement
and note that beliefs differ from
knowledge in the conviction with which
they are held and in the
self-referential element they embed
beliefs are also different from
attitudes by focusing on the true false
dimension rather than on the good bad
dimension
and normative models of belief change
have proposed that beliefs change on the
basis of new evidence
and indeed many information campaigns
rely on a rational model of belief
update
in my work i adopt a sociocognitive
framework to study belief change that
complements this classic view by showing
how superficial features of the belief
evaluation experience can also impact
beliefs
and showing how these features can be
leveraged to change false beliefs in
interventions
but investigating beliefs only at the
individual level would miss essential
processes that occur when people
interact giving rise to emergent
collective phenomena
indeed recent research has shown that
communities of individuals are
characterized by shared attention
collective memory collective emotions
collective actions
and understanding these collective
processes
involves uncovering the socio-cognitive
processes that lead to their emergence
and to visualize the basic principle
behind this idea
imagine a social network of
interconnected people
if we pick a cognitive process and for
example upregulate it in an intervention
the social network might become
polarized on a given issue
on the other hand if instead we
downregulate that same process at the
individual level the collective outcome
can look very different in an unexpected
way
so in this presentation i'll show how
these often asymmetric dynamics
occur in collective beliefs
and i'll also propose a framework for
investigating future such emergent
phenomena
this framework relies on first
identifying individual level cognitive
effects such as various mechanisms of
belief change
the framework then suggests exploring
individual effects diets of interacting
individuals
to observe their manifestation in a
social context
and finally the framework recommends
investigating effects in communities to
understand how they propagate through
social networks
here i'll apply this framework to study
collective beliefs and specifically
i ask how the micro level cognitive
process of changing a belief
can trigger macro level collective
belief change
the first individual mechanism of belief
change i'll present here leverages
mnemonic accessibility
in the study builds on the literature
characterizing memory as constructive
and malleable
in this work memory had been found to
impact beliefs through a process called
the illusory truth effect
which refers to the increase in belief
endorsement for familiar information
in other words an upregulation of memory
has been shown to lead to an increase in
belief endorsement and given this
finding
our question was whether a down
regulation of memory would decrease
belief endorsement
to investigate participants were asked
to rate the accuracy of a set of 24
health statements organized across
categories
and then participants listened to
another person mentioning a selected
subset of these initial statements in
only some of the initial categories
and this manipulation had been shown to
upregulate the memory for the practiced
information while then regulating the
memory for the related but not practiced
information compared to unrelated
information
participants were then asked to recall
the initial statements in an incidental
cute recall task
and finally to evaluate the initial
statements again at posttest
the typical convention for labeling the
items in this paradigm is that the
practice items can be labeled as rp plus
the within category not practice items
are rp minus and the outside of category
are on nrp or no ritual practice items
so here i apply these three item types
on the x-axis and on the y-axis i'll
plot belief change from pre-test to
post-test
and in two samples of princeton students
we find that the practice items here in
red became more believable
and the unpracticed items here in blue
became less believable than the
unrelated items here in green
therefore down regulating memory
resulted in a decrease in believability
however these effects only held for
initially moderately endorsed beliefs so
not for extremely endorsed or extremely
opposed beliefs
the take of this study is that to
decrease a moderate belief strength one
strategy could be creating the context
to discuss related information
also at the individual level we assessed
how different ways of presenting
evidence can lead to different levels of
belief change
so in this study we draw from research
on the associative learning theory
introduced in 1972
suggesting that while predictions that
are confirmed consolidate knowledge
predictions that are violated or
prediction errors are used as cues to
adjust future predictions accordingly
and this adjustment is proportional to
the difference between the prediction
and new information acquired and this
law of update had been shown to apply to
perception
memory learning cognitive control
decision making and other cognitive
functions
in the study we're investigating whether
this law holds for beliefs
so first participants rated the accuracy
of a set of 36 general knowledge
statements
enrolled in assigned to one of two
conditions control or prediction
in the control condition participants
were given a set of statistical facts
that served as evidence
whereas in the prediction condition
participants were asked to predict each
statistical fact and were then given the
correct answer on a scale
and the distance between participants
prediction and the correct answer was
computed as the size of the prediction
error
lastly participants were asked to rate
the accuracy of the initial statements
again
we recruited a main sample of 704 in a
replication of a nationally
representative sample of 1073 cloud
research workers
and the results plotted here as the
prediction error size against belief
change show a linear relationship
between the size of the error
participants made and the degree to
which they changed their beliefs as a
result
moreover we find that it's when
participants make the largest errors
that they update their beliefs more than
in the control condition
we also find that these effects hold
across political ideologies in our case
us's democrats and republicans and
regardless of belief's type democratic
republican or neutral
this finding suggests that an effective
strategy of changing beliefs
can be the dissemination of surprising
evidence in a prediction and feedback
format which will trigger large
prediction errors and lead to rational
belief updating
finally at the individual level we
wondered how social norms can be used to
change beliefs
and here we build on the vast literature
on the impact of social norms in
people's lives
for instance theoretical work on social
consensus proposes that a large group of
people believing a piece of information
act as a secondary reality test making
that piece of information more likely to
be believed
moreover empirical work shows that
information that appears as normative
for example if a tweet has a lot of
likes
is rated as more believable than
information that appears as
non-normative
here i'm interested in whether this
effect can be used to change a belief
so to investigate participants first
rated the accuracy of a set of 32 health
statements after which they were exposed
to a set of tweets serving as evidence
either in favor or against these initial
statements
and while half of the tweets were
designed to have a large number of likes
in the normative condition
the other half had only a small number
of likes in the non-normative condition
so here's an example of a tweet we
created for the non-normative condition
lastly participants rated the statements
again at posttest and in a sample of 200
princeton students i found that
statements followed by normative
evidence here in red
changed more in line with the evidence
compared with statements followed by
normative evidence
and this effect was mediated by how
convincing the evidence was perceived
therefore to change a belief one should
provide normative evidence
so seeing the strong impact of social
normativity cues on belief change made
us wonder if the source of the
normativity cue also mattered in
determining how beliefs can change
so we tested whether large groups of
people
individual people experts or political
leaders would be more effective at
changing people's beliefs
participants rated a set of statements
after which they were shown how much
other people believe these statements
intend between subject conditions
we had a control condition with no
additional information
we had three groups of prior
participants either non-specific or
denoted as democrats or republicans
a health expert an anecdote or a
political leader
then participants rated again the
believability of the initial statements
and here i'm plotting the change in
knowledge on the x-axis as a function of
these 10 conditions on the y
and higher knowledge means that means an
increase in belief in true information
but also a decreasing belief in false
information
and here we find that compared to the
control condition
participants increase their knowledge
more when evidence was presented by a
non-descript group of prior participants
we did not find any source interaction
with participants political affiliation
suggesting that democrats and
republicans were similarly affected by
information sources
in ongoing work we're exploring the
mechanisms driving these findings
so in summary at the individual level i
described several ways in which beliefs
can be changed that complement the
rational model of belief update
for instance belief endorsement can be
changed by manipulating mnemonic
accessibility
triggering prediction errors or making
normativity cues salient
so the next step in the social
interactionist approach is exploring how
such effects occur in dyadic contexts
so at this level we built on the
literature on social influence showing
how thinking is socially constructed
leading to an alignment between
interacting individuals
we wanted to see how the synchronization
might shape belief change
and to investigate we asked participants
to write a set of statements
after which we paired them in groups of
two and instructed them to discuss the
statements
lastly we asked participants to write
the statements again a posttest
and here on the x-axis i'll plot how
much the conversational partner endorsed
or opposed each statement in the
conversation
and on the y-axis how much the
participants changed their beliefs to
match what the partner had said
the results showed that participants
were very sensitive to their
conversational partners and increased
their beliefs in the statements their
partners endorsed
while decreasing their beliefs in the
statements their partners refuted
this pattern was strongest for initially
moderately held beliefs depicted here in
yellow
the takeaway of the study being that
individuals are sensitive
to their conversational partners
so finally to investigate how individual
cognitive effects propagate in social
networks
we
picked the memory impact of on beliefs
that i described in study one
and our paradigm at the collective level
mimics scenarios in which individuals
first listen to a public speaker
that reiterates some of their beliefs
and then communicate with one another
within their social networks about those
beliefs
to investigate the collective belief
dynamic of a group of people who
encounter such a situation
we invite participants into the lab in
groups of 12 to form a lab-created
social network
participants first evaluated the
believability of a set of health beliefs
organized across categories
after which some of the social networks
listened to a public speaker selectively
mentioning a subset of the previously
evaluated beliefs in the practice
condition
while the control networks filled out a
distracted task
and then all participants engaged in
conversational interactions within their
social networks following the temporally
unfolding conversational network
structure depicted here in four rounds
with each link between participants
depicting a dyadic interaction
so here we created a network that mimics
the main characteristics of real-world
social networks
clustered communities characterized by
frequent within cluster interactions
and lastly participants rated the
statements again and then a third time
after one week
we recruited a sample of 168 princeton
students to form 14 12-member
communities
and found that participants in the
practice networks synchronized their
beliefs with each other more than
participants in the control networks by
increasing their practice beliefs here
in orange but also by decreasing their
unpracticed beliefs here in blue
the finding that mnemonic accessibility
increases collective belief
synchronization made us wonder to what
degree the network structure that people
were embedded in mattered in how this
collective belief formed
so to investigate participants in
another study rated the accuracy of a
set of health statements after which
they were exposed to evidence either in
favor or against these initial
statements
and were then directed to the
conversational interaction phase in
which they had conversations with other
participants in their networks following
a temporary unfolding conversational
network structure in five rounds
lastly participants rated the statements
again
i recruited a sample of 140 princeton
students to form 14 10-member
communities
and to test whether the structure of the
network influenced the degree of
synchronization
we first constructed a hypothesis matrix
representing each network structure by
mapping for each pair of participants in
the network their distance from each
other in degrees of separation
we then computed the empirical data
matrix which contained the changing
correlations of beliefs for each pair of
participants
and write an unparametric statistical
test or bootstrap
to assess whether the empirical matrices
were better explained by the true
network structure than by any other
randomized network structure of
equivalent constraints that we simulated
and indeed found support for these
hypotheses meaning that belief
synchronization was determined by the
structure of the network that the
individuals were embedded in
in summary this research program can
issue a series of empirically driven
recommendations for policy makers
interested in changing beliefs in a
targeted fashion
for instance the strategy of increasing
mnemonic accessibility works best on
strongly endorsed beliefs
but different strategies worked better
at different levels of initial
endorsement
for instance a strategy that i didn't
discuss here but involves increasing
emotional arousal is most effective in
the case of initially strongly opposed
beliefs
and revealing the source worked best on
the case of moderately endorsed beliefs
so taking all of these findings together
to change a belief that is strongly
endorsed one could either increase its
mnemonic accessibility or trigger large
prediction errors
however if that beliefs is only
moderately endorsed the options are to
decrease its accessibility reveal the
information source or trigger large
prediction errors
and if the belief is initially strongly
opposed one could either associate it
with emotional images
emphasize social norms or trigger large
prediction errors
and if one engages in either of these
strategies at the level of the community
one could expect people's beliefs to
change to align with each other
conversations to amplify individual
processes
and people's beliefs to change according
to their network structure
so now let me give you a brief flavor of
some current research directions i'm
excited about
first i'm interested in understanding
the psychological drivers of climate
beliefs and climate action
this research stems from the newest
reports by the un warning that wildfires
floods drought and rising sea levels
will become more and more frequent when
you project projections showing that as
increasing parts of the world become
uninhabitable the displacements of
billions of people will create a refugee
crisis that could lead to worldwide
economic collapse
unless of course we engage in
coordinated global action
so in my current work i'm applying
sociocognitive strategies to stimulate
collective climate action
in an ongoing international
collaboration i'm comparing the
state-of-the-art collective climate
action interventions in a randomized
controlled trial conducted in over 80
countries around the world
in this experiment we're testing both
individual level climate action for
example tree planting efforts
as well as collective climate action
such as supporting climate policy
and these are the 11 interventions we're
testing which we chose in design with
input from our over 200 collaborators
and these are the projected relative
effectiveness as rated by our
collaborators
so we look forward to these um results
and to compare these predictions with
the actual results of the interventions
so stay tuned for these findings
projected to be collected by the end of
this year
in current work i'm also interested in
the role of artificial intelligence in
shaping our worldview beliefs
and this research trajectory is
motivated by the numerous instances of
algorithmic oppression
recently uncovered ranging from hiring
to university admissions the criminal
sentencing and healthcare allocation to
name a few
but what causes such biases
a common assumption is that they reflect
existing disparities existing in society
representing in the data on which these
algorithms are trained
however if this is the case there's a
risk that their outputs could propagate
these existing biases back into society
therefore thereby creating this
reinforcing bias of inequality
this perspective suggests that ai
decision tools could potentially
contribute to a cycle of perpetuating
inequality
to investigate this hypothesis we first
assess the relationship between existing
societal inequality and algorithmic
search output inequality in the context
of gender in two multinational studies
we first say the hypothesis that the
degree of gender inequality within a
society
would predict a pattern of algorithmic
gender inequality in internet search
outputs
and to investigate we obtained an open
source data set
known as the global gender gap index
computed by the world economic forum
containing rankings of gender inequality
for each country in the world
and to develop an assessment of gender
bias in algorithmic output we drew upon
classic research on the prototype bias
by which words such as person
student or human
are more often assumed to be a man
indeed recent research with using
national natural language processing to
analyze billions of words on the
internet also showed that the concept of
person
is more similar to that of men than to
that of women
and online algorithms to
designed to translate make gender biased
errors assigning a masculine gender to
professions such as doctor despite the
original sentence implying a woman
based on this research we developed an
approach which involved conducting
google image searches for the keyword
person
in each country using a vpn and
computing a gender bias score for each
country using the ratio of men to women
results in the first hundred images
using this approach should collect the
data in over 50 countries
and to assess our central hypotheses we
tested the relation between the global
gender gap on the x-axis and the degree
of gender disparity in these image
outputs on the y-axis and this effect
was highly significant such that the
proportion of male images was higher in
nations with greater inequality
in an initial sample of 37 countries and
a replication of 52 countries
therefore studies one and two provide
empirical evidence that societal level
gender disparities are reflected in
algorithmic outputs
having demonstrated this association
between gender inequality and
algorithmic output we turn to our next
question
whether exposure to such algorithmic
outputs can shape people cognitive's
concept and decisions in matters
consistent with this pre-existing
inequality thereby completing the cycle
of bias propagation
to investigate we recruited a sample of
u.s participants and presented them with
images depicting the google image search
results of new professions
and the gender composition of these
professions was manipulated to display
gender ratios of high inequality nations
for example approximately 90 men in
hungary or turkey
or low gender inequality nations with 50
50 men to women in iceland or finland
the procedure was the following first
participants made prototypicality
judgments regarding a new profession for
example they were asked who is more
likely to be a perker a man or a woman
and then participants were told they
would be able to see the google image
search results for these professions
and we randomly assign the professions
to appear in either the high or the low
inequality condition
as you can see here in the high
inequality condition
we
showed mostly men building wigs
and in a low inequality condition we
showed a ratio of one-to-one mental
women building wigs
and then we asked participants again
the prototypicality
question after which they were faced
with the first choice decision task in
which they had to choose between two
applicants for a job in each of the
professions that they learned about
here are the results plotted as the low
and high inequality conditions
against the proportion of women chosen
in the task and the 50 dollar line
represents no gender bias
at pre-test participants thought men
were more likely to perform the new
professions
and this replicates the male default
bias
i post this however per type ratings
became more egalitarian in the low
compared to the high inequality
condition
indeed exposure to search results
pattern found in the low inequality
nations reversed participants male bias
prototypes whereas exposure to search
results patterns found in the high
inequality nations appear to reinforce
and maintain this prototype
exposure to image sets in the low
inequality condition also produce a
higher likelihood of choosing women as
the job candidates
in a mediation analysis our overarching
prediction was supported exposure to
high versus low inequality search
results
shaped gender prototype formation which
in turn influence gender-biased hiring
in conclusion in two sets of
cross-national studies we provide
empirical evidence that societal
inequality is reflected in algorithmic
inequality
and that algorithmic inequality
influences decisions aligning with this
inequality further reinforcing the
pattern of discrimination in a
self-perpetrating cycle of bias
propagation
this finding suggests that new
intervention points for bias reduction
may involve uncovering how human
decision makers interact with
algorithmic outputs
together these research directions
aspire to advance our understanding of
some of the critical challenges facing
our society
growing inequality and the climate
crisis in my new lab at nyu we'll
continue focusing on these two
applications of collective cognitive
processes
and with that i would like to thank my
collaborators my funding sources and
more importantly all of you for
listening and i'm looking forward to
your questions so please email me if you
would like to further discuss
hi thank you for coming to my talk